dans l'acte de vente us avec il est
exploité sur savais que tu l'avais payé
moins cher pour ça mais tu savais pas
que c'était un squat permanence et ça
c'est ça c'est ce que je dis depuis le
début un jour d'essence que j'ai depuis
le début j'ai précisé qu'ils avaient
toujours un rien eu un match dont tu
t'es demande quoi imaginer pourquoi tu
t'es dit que tu avais payé cette maison
beaucoup moins cher pour sa passagère
avant la maison qu'elle est dans un sale
état il faut faire il faut faire
l'isolation il ya une chute de la
chaudière a changé c'est au fioul il
faut faire l'assainissement électricité
n'est pas aux normes là il ya de
l'amiante la plomberie j'ai tout à
refaire ma maison pourquoi la personne
- quatre personnes ont prouvé mon cas
ils sont partis aux lois ils sont partis
par là
je la leur et alexandre ils sont partis
là comme nestlé ou pas c'est bizarre à
sa femme à accoucher aux côtés ça va
alors c'est quoi qui fait la femme de
castaldi
dans le public
alors mettez moi quelqu'un de volumineux
ici mais toi
t'es qu'un volumineux voilà
alors oui j'ai été choqué par la manière
dont on a traité laurent hier soir on
l'a traité comme un coupable alors qu'il
est victime encore une fois dans cette
affaire et en fait on donne raison aux
squatteurs ça quand vous êtes vous
voulez quoi qu'ils payent une maison
140000 euros et qu'ils ne puissent
jamais habité dedans je suis sonné une
maison occupée par des squatters dans
laquelle on ne peut jamais habité ça ne
vaut pas 140000 euros ça vaut zéro euro
et bravo à lui s'il a fait une affaire
d'état
c'est un détail on sent qu'il a menti
par omission mais non mais c'est pas
important il faut qu'ils nous donnent
tous les tenants et les aboutissants de
voir en se donnant pour acquise à partir
du moment où il met des récits donne
bien exactement ce qui s'est passé
précisément sauf que si nous le dit on
n'invite pas de la même manière elle
savait pas le buzz ce qui on te c'est de
vendre une maison squattée c'est de
squatter une maison rien pour moi elle a
acheté agent immobilier il a dit il ya
un business mais ça pue la
circulation c'est un fait
et grandes histoires de ce parisien qui
rappelle qu'ils ont demandé à plusieurs
reprises au couple d'acheteurs s'il est
au courant que la maison était occupée a
tenu à s'adresser aux lecteurs parce que
c'est enfin dévoilé la faire en premier
dans notre premier article publié le 8
juin consacré à l'histoire rapportée par
laurent elodie on peut lire que le
couple d'acheteurs de la ville nous
montre des photos d'une maison vide
pour preuve de leur bonne foi lors de
leur visite en septembre 2021 contacté
au téléphone jeudi après la découverte
de ce nouveau document le propriétaire
de la maison squattée a reconnu une mise
en scène de leur jeu de clés pour faire
genre
que vous lisez loin répond sincèrement
que ce couple malgré nos précautions et
nos vérifications d usage et puis
sciemment
vous induire en erreur et nous nous en
excusons sincèrement auprès de nos
lecteurs nous réfutons toute accusation
de diffusion intentionnelle de fausses
informations depuis le premier article
publié nous avons importé tauriel et
précision de cette histoire que nous ne
manquerons pas de suivre ultérieurement
jeter en acier marc pierre bellemare
parisien
l'ovale
ici sur le plateau est ce que sur le
plateau il a dit que cette mise en scène
elle été induite par leurs maris ziane
imposé l'an là le parisien dick 7 euros
fait encore et encore baleine sous
gravillon en guise sur le fond le
parisien en plus ils sont ils sont
furieux parce que il y avait sorti la
faire et ils ont l'impression que le
couple confie voilà le sait alors moi
j'ai pas mal de témoignages d'habitants
d'arpajon ses à côtés dans la vie la
laiterie motivation ouais bah oui mais
ne j'avais un pote qui avait une île de
ré la base légale ou le roi du lot
allure mégalo le roi du lot les
chaussures à 22 euros
à
dire que tout le monde savait que cette
maison connue était squatté que les
enfants du couple qui souhaitait jouer
dans le jardin depuis des mois donc
c'est strictement impossible que le
couple n'ait pas su que la maison était
squatté par cette famille nombreuse
ensuite il ya des vidéos qui tournent 2
avec des gens du parti reconquête d'eric
zemmour beaucoup de vidéos où on les
voit en scène avec reconquête donc
beaucoup de gens dans la région se
demande s'il n'ya pas de leur part une
volonté à quelques jours des élections
d'avoir médias tg une affaire pour des
raisons privées de recaser médiatiser
une affaire mais des récits c'est-à-dire
taz est une affaire électorale voilà
nokia beaucoup de choses ça commence à
faire beaucoup sans compter les infos
vous allez nous donne et créeront un qui
viennent de tomber yemelin vont venir
dans un après juste mathieu n'était pas
là hier j'aimerais avoir son avis pour
les spectateurs puisque vous nous avez
regardé hier partie des nombreux
téléspectateurs je le sais qu'ils s'en
servent à être présent ce gentil alors
effectivement j'ai regardé hier ben moi
je soutiens que j'étais là lors de la
première émission que deux sont venus en
victimes tous les deux comme ça on était
choqués victimes de squatters ils ont
acheté une maison avec toute la gct les
économies d'une vie qu'ils aient mis
dans cette maison et la loi est mal
faite et heureusement darmana arrive et
hier j'avais deux mecs qui veulent pas
d'un couple qui était très raisonnée
très froid qui expliquait que la
chaudière est à refaire cas de l'amiante
qui a ceci que cela et qui venait
justifier une arnaque totale mais une
arnaque totale bravo le parisien balaton
transplante men arnaque totale donc
derrière s'est pas trouvée
le président moi je dis bravo de paris
ils ont suivi de bouder les peaux mixtes
et berné comme non mais aussi iron
man a aussi si tu la fermes et des
appareils mais voilà donc voilà ils ont
quand même bien bienvenue et je trouve
ils ont fait une heure en vrai si on est
cynique et ccc ils ont faim derrière de
fou d'histoire était amusant 140000
euros et ils vont et vous ils ont gagné
vous veniez action gagner 50 70 euros
sur cette maison mais les indices us de
danse et peut-être à la finale tout ça
quoi c'était pas moi
même personne leurs proches oui
répondent encore n'accepte en acquiert
n'accepte pas le fait que ce soit pas
moral mais ils ont fait appel à un effet
d'émulation oui mais comment les prendre
pour des cons sur un plateau télé pour
sortir c'est juste que ça fait peut-être
partie de leur plancher mais les médias
dedans tu vois c est
révélé hier raymond ah c'était ça c'est
ça c'est à dix les 50 60 mille euros
c'est ils ont acheté une maison trop bas
du prix et moi j'ai dit alors je vais
dire tu sors pas de chez le notaire sans
les clés et après tu peux faire ça mais
tu vas pas médiatisé moi ce que j'ai pas
aimé c'est qui médiatise ça aurait pu
être dangereux pour la famille qui
habite dedans il ya peut-être des gens
convaincus à leurs mercenaires vouloir
les sortir
les enfants c'est très grave quand tu
viens ici dire comme ça dit mathieu
c'est vrai on était tout seul attendri
mais
tu peux tu peux faire des dégâts
collatéraux en est mais qui peuvent
aller là-bas la paix tu vois vous étiez
passé dans la nuit c'est peut-être me
suis lâché entre guillemets comme comme
kelly a dit la morale là dedans c'est
peut-être chiant pour la mort 1 mais là
si la récupère à 140 milles il va faire
des travaux peut-être que joueur et un
camp et la revente de sens que je vais
me permettre de citer d'aidé
et un grand auteur qui dit c'est pas bon
pour la morale
l'école oui c'est ça
non mais c'est vrai c'est pas bon pour
la morale un petit coup pour balancer
une caresse pour décoller
non ce qu'elle veut monique catta hervé
monique des journées non mais c'est là
bas si je te jure abbas et le deuxième
jeu toujours c'est monique de la macif
d'animer la raison sur lens non mais
t'as une teinte appelé monica ouais
c'est les devins vous lisez en moi comme
dans un livre ouvert on va faire le
livre
[Applaudissements]
une faillite il
attendait sur une page en examen spears
et cette vieille expression ils ont
voulu le beurre l'argent du beurre et le
cul de la crémière ben moi juste le cul
de la crémière mais non mais c'est
exactement ça jouer mais c'est
franchement et moi ce que je veux c'est
vraiment que ça c'est ce que je disais
hier ça va discréditer il ya vraiment
des gens qui sont venus de quelques d'un
petit séjour et qui ont trouvé des
squatteurs et là on ne va pas pu croire
à ces histoires de squatters donc moi je
trouve ça vraiment scandale après faut
lutter
maintenant ils nous ont vraiment pour
monique j'ai des informations
certes elle qui vient de faire des
révélations sur le couple alors chan
c'est franchement mais ce alors je vous
dis c'est d'avoir mieux mais c'est pas
pour ça que ils ont effet interne
efficace et juste ils ont fait des
révélations sur le coup il serait mis en
examen depuis octobre dernier pour
trafic de stupéfiants pour la détention
illicite d'armes de catégorie b et c
[Applaudissements]
c'est à y aller c'est un chouïa
c'est rien à perdre
mais attendez ce n'est pas fini non donc
génois non mais c'est vrai donc et une
désinformation qui se sentit donc il
serait mis en examen depuis octobre
dernier donc pour trafic de stupéfiants
détention illicite d'armes de catégorie
b et c et participation à une
association de malfaiteurs en vue de la
préparation d'un déni
[Applaudissements]
il aimait tout le danger
ce serait tout sépare et ça c'était pas
ça ne veut rien dire jeudi midi
l'intérieur la première chose c'est
terrifiant
voilà c'est dit c'est au chaudron non
mais ça montre un peu l'état d'esprit
mako était trop trop non mais ça montre
les apôtres certes élu les infos c'est
que ministre de l'intérieur il va les
avoir il les a eus la
viande et avoir d'abord les enfants
derrière moi le parquet a confirmé le
parquet a cherché
ils sont placés sous la houlette
de patricia cyril ça remet tout en cause
il faut pas oublier que mine de rien
comme a dit guillaume au départ la
maison était secoué l'île alors oui mais
tout dépend de moi je vous dis ans de
l'histoire ils ont avec elle ils
savaient ils savaient qu'ils exploitent
et je pense voilà ils ont fait une
simulation ils se sont débrouillés pour
faire sortir les squatteurs ils ont
réussi leur coup et là et je pense
qu'ils vont faire une plus value de 50 à
60 mille euros donc il ne rien voilà
nous ont fait ils envoient beaucoup
après c'est vrai qu'on avait des airs
tels a fait des révélations est
d'ailleurs laurent on l'a invité demain
pour qu'il revienne encore s'écoule à
répondre à la barbade qui répondent à la
réponse
il serait mis donc comme je vous le dis
en examen depuis octobre dernier pour
trafic de stupéfiants détention illicite
d'armes de catégorie b et si mais si
vous savez ce que c'était désormais en
catégorie b et c couteau suisse
et couteaux guy degrenne
et participation à une association de
malfaiteurs en vue de la préparation
d'un délit mais un ennui et aussi
apparemment ignoré
que vous avez dit que j'allais moi je
n'ai rien dit bon d'accord vous n'avez
pas d'autres infos gilles verdez cyril
très gras maintenant présomption
d'innocence mais là la raison du haut
niveau c'est pas parce que alors je vous
dire mais sa mère parce que peut être un
truc c on est malhonnête surtout non je
suis désolé il a pu faire des erreurs
voilà oui j'allais juste dire
présomption d'innocence mais les motifs
de mise en examen sont quand même très
grave il faut savoir que ça relève de la
prison ferme de nombreuses années de
prison si c'est confirmé
au parquet de créteil ça veut dire que
ça pas été commis dans l'essonne enfin
ça n'aurait pas été commis dans
l'essonne mais dans le val de marne
créteil voilà donc maintenant cyril très
franchement comment voulez vous prendre
au sérieux l'achat d'une maison à 180
euros d'où vient l'argent non mais de
qui est ce couple qui s occupe un rang
des conduites nous quoi mais gyan têtu
fédéral répond aux mêmes enjeux
devraient pas y songer à des raccourcis
les radiations en train de sortir des
dossiers sur ce couple pour l'aider à
celle visée mais plutôt à la base ce
sont des victimes non vous êtes en train
d'inventer mise et les squatteurs qui
n'ont pas le droit d'être là et à vous
écouter on dit que vous vouliez en fait
qui paye la maison 140000 euros je pense
jamais à réussir il mènera les
différents corps avec
séoul life is technologiques et des
ménages
c'est pour ça qu'il aimait manger vite
et william étaient victimes de mer du
cogneur on avance sur la faire et qu'on
lieu de te tirer des conclusions en
train de réactiver exactement et gilles
verdez il retourne dans le lot de
panneaux tu veux pas un peu con et
toutes les infos rhénan tu retombes dans
l'autre panneaux il les a désinformées
nord tu les as pas encore tue l'ehpad
aux infos sur d'autres affaires et des
renards les appareils de série la pro a
et roger malgré tout sur le profil ces
gens là oui alors moi je n'aime pas ce
mot les profils de ces gens-là ça veut
dire si on a fait des bêtises d'amidon
sais pas si on a fait ça mais maintenant
oui mais c'était pour après ses membres
non son jeu sur mon son chiril ça ils ne
l'ont pas dit quand il aura ce soir il
aura avec laurent de makeni vouliez dire
un truc non on a quand même quelques
infos qui sont avérées qui nous a dit
lui même en plateau donc c'est pas comme
si on n'avait rien après ghost on a
placé des victimes mais on a eu la
preuve hier que ce n'était pas des
victimes parce qu'ils sont ils étaient
au courant de ce qu'ils achetaient et
qu'il y avait déjà des squatteurs donc à
quel niveau ce sont des victimes accor
tient moment où d'accord pour enquiller
matar quand on achète une maison à
gloucester c'est pas pour les coller
squatteurs reste à vie en fait
c'était pas victimes
bravo à tomber demain je t'achète
d'aventuré tu me dis elle a pas deux
roues balisage est moins cher qu'avec
des rhumes j'ai pas victime je sais qu'à
leur deux roues mais sur castanet sa
marque
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
activement sur ma maison ils ont rien
fait d'illégal bien sûr il ya eu des
recettes générées sur la sur l'argile
arias je pense qu'en france tu peux pas
sortir 140000 euros comme ça en espèces
dans une valise c'est forcément sur des
concerts justification
après et le prêt tu justifies comment tu
vas ils ont faim crédit tu peux pas être
endetté a fait 33 % tous assez carré
tout ce qu'ils ont fait c'est légal pour
l'instant il suis dit si ça qu'ils ont
déconné tout ce qu'ils ont fait dans la
maison nommé hier la promesse d'un
notaire il n'arrive pas taris pas chez
un auteur tient alors chéri parce que
les
notaires c'est ça bien sûr un auteur
c'est sérieux comme ça le notaire il dit
ne ressentir mois de notaire véreux il
ya pas d être à l écoute à ce moment là
comme à 10 irin en rond s'enflamme pas
et une enquête qui va être là je pense
pas qu'un notaire pas se [ __ ] dans la
merde pour l'heure si on sent
donc ils assez con pour se montrer à la
télé que c'est risqué risque qu'il y
adhérer moi je crois pas moi je pense
que sur ça ça fait que tout choix sur
cette affaire voilà c'est juste qu'il
avait agi légalement ou à berner tout le
monde en vendre en pleurant pour faire
sortir les mecs plus vite mais ils sont
sortis voilà c'était quoi que c'était
une stratégie la vapeur qui savent ce
qu'il faut faire c'est avec celle là
j'ai regarder cela de défenseur des
causes perdues donne vraiment à nokia
chinoise elle
qu'est ce que tu veux comme je voulais
simplement vous dire je suis aussi une
enquête sur la manière dans la famille
qui a quitté la maison a été traitée de
violences menaces et on va lui chercher
10 rc la médiathèque ça c'est la
médiatisation j'ajoute que il faudra ce
que je disais hier vous avez dit mais
ils n'ont aucun intérêt à ce que ce soit
oui oui n'importe où ça va mais aucun
intérêt l'enquêté dira écoutez je vais
tenir on a vu ce que tu données sur les
émissions de faits divers ça dure une
semaine succès tient bon
baby maintenant d'identité sur les
verbes sur les mariages n'allez pas
sur les a30 castaldi je vais prendre la
défense de même pour la défendre merci
non
mais c'est pas tout seul en plus ce
n'est pas crédible qu'un papier alu là
c'est non mais c'est très lourd de
canettes jeu très beau et très belle
mais géraldine t'emmerde pas il serait
bienvenu on est là par un pas que les
phocéens et vous rigolez non parce que
j'ai des anthologies quand je suis
d'accord avec quelqu'un même si je le
déteste par ailleurs
dacca c'est sympa
et n'oubliez jamais c'est moi ceux qui
sont derrière toute cette affaire c'est
désormais le rigolo qui tu as écrite
ça c'est la bonne a dit mme amos a cessé
d'appeler le concours une femme à son
mari c'est l'habitude c'est toujours ça
fatou on n'arrive jamais à se marier
elle n'a pas arrêté leur ep au village
il voit le pauvre gilles et là vous êtes
construit un truc de dingue
est-ce que vous avez tort moi je suis
quand même plus gentil ou rigologie non
merci devrait évoquer
des fonds c'est
génial savage et nous n'en fait pas bien
et moi c'est génial ce que tu as fait
sur les
bonis que ça super une
lame à monique on y craint supporter
hendaye en
appelant la ville a tué monique savoie
j'étais scandalisé des veillées la suite
on a vite changé
quoi tu as eu du mal à dormir vraiment
pris pour des cons et ils à la mer n'est
hélas pas dormir leurs moyens truc en
amont à moi mon qui me choque je
voudrais quand même le dire c'est que
gérald darmanin appris ça il a cru sam
hamad a cessé il a cru que c'était du
vrai il a une armée c'est du vrai mélo
c'est du frais il a donc dos mais si tu
ferais l'histoire a engagé là il a
résolu le problème en fait on a des ans
deux pays rapportent ce qui veut dire
que c'est possible il faut que je sois
médiatisé pour fêter
la raison l'a refusée mais c'est un vrai
premier problème je suis désolé il faut
faire pleurer dans les chaumières pour
que monsieur darmanin demande un préfet
de faire quelque chose plus tôt mais
n'avaient des bad boys il peut pas être
au courant de tout acte et jack white
c'est malsain mais c'est que la loi est
là il est au courant de rien mais oui ou
non mais peut le faire alors pourquoi on
le fait que pour quelqu'un et
c'est normal je suis désolé soir viens
de dire
[Applaudissements]
mais la poésie c'est pas monique
qui est avec nous c'est vraiment une
tête à vous appeler money 602e
guy monier
abonnés lundi la nouvelle et belle
victoire
qui la tient moi je
[Rires]
aller